بدات مجموعه بريكس تجمعا اقتصاديا دون ان
تغيب عنه الرؤيه السياسيه بالكامل انطلقت
باجتماع عقد في روسيا وتشكلت بدايه باسم
بريك عام 2009 من الصين وروسيا والبرازيل
والهند لتنضم جنوب افريقيا وتتخذ المجموعه
اسمها الحالي براكس
تركزت اهداف بريكس على تحقيق نمو
الاقتصادي وتعزيز التنميه والامن والسلام
لتحقيق الاستقرار السياسي والاقتصادي
واصلاح المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه وتفعيل
التجاره الدوليه والاستثمار وتفعيل تبادل
العملات المحليه بين دول المجموعه وانشاء
سوق مشتركه للتجاره وعمله موحده في محاوله
للخروج من اشتراطات صندوق النقد الدولي
التي تصفها المجموعه بالمجحفه بدات بريكس
بطرح ما قد يكون بدائل للنظام الذي تهيمن
عليه دول الشمال فرغم انها تضم
42% من سكان العالم الا ان اعضائها الخمسه
لديهم اقل من 15% من حقوق التصويت في
البنك وصندوق النقد الدوليين مقابل نحو
17% للولايات المتحده وخمسه واربعين في
المئه لمجموعه السبع
تستحوذ دول المجموعه على اكثر من
31% من الناتج الاجمالي العالمي بحجم
اقتصاد يتجاوز اربعه واربعين تريليون
دولار مقابل اكثر من 30% من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي لدول مجموعه السبع وحجم
اقتصاد يقارب واحد واربعين تريليون دولار
تسهم دول المجموعه بنحو
23% من الاقتصاد العالمي ونحو
من تجاره السلع العالميه تنتج دول
المجموعه 30% من السلع والمنتجات عالميا
وتتحكم بخمسين في المئه من احتياطي الذهب
والعملات وتنتج المجموعه ما يزيد على
اربعين في المئه من مصادر الطاقه العالميه
نقاط قوه بريكس دفعت قرابه اربعين دوله
للسعي للانضمام للمجموعه ومن بينها
الجزائر ومصر والسعوديه ودول عربيه وشرق
اوسطيه وسيشكل انضمامها محطه مهمه في تحول
موازين القوى الاقتصاديه العالميه ولم تجد
فكره انشاء مؤسسات دوليه موازيه للمؤسسات
الاقتصاديه الحاليه عن اجنده المجموعه
انشات بريكس بنك التنميه الجديد براس مال
قدره 50 مليار دولار ويسعى للوصول الى 100
مليار دولار كما اسست المجموعه الصندوقا
اطلق عليه صندوق الاحتياطي النقدي يتضمن
احتياطيات نقديه طارئه بقيمه 100 مليار
دولار تدعم الدول لسداد ديونها وتسعى دول
المجموعه الى اقرار نظام دفع وتحويلات
ماليه جديد متعدد الاطراف والجنسيات ليشكل
بديلا لنظام الدفع الامريكي سويفت